-Our first guest tonight served
as United States senator
from Massachusetts,
and secretary of state
for President Obama.
He is now the special
presidential envoy for climate,
as part of the United States
National Security Council.
Please welcome back
to the show John Kerry.
[ Applause ]
♪♪
-Hi, Seth.
-Thank you for being back.
-Good to see you, man.
-Good to see you, too.
Thank you.
♪♪
-Welcome. It is lovely
to have you here.
I know we have you here in town
because of the UN.
Do you feel like
you're making progress?
-Yeah, I do.
Can I begin just by saying
thank you for doing this,
for joining with your fellow
late night hosts?
It's fantastic and you do
an incredible Bernie Sanders.
-Thank you.
-It's great.
-That means the most to me
and I only wish
my Bernie could stop
the warming of our planet.
[ Laughter ]
-I think he's warming
the planet, actually.
-Yeah, maybe just get him
to quiet down a little.
I want to ask real quick
because the UN had maybe --
and, again, you're a big star,
special envoy --
but, on Monday...
-I don't know.
-...BTS performed.
-I know. I know. They're great.
-John Kerry's a BTS fan?
-I watched the video there.
You know, what is it,
"Permission to Dance"
or something?
It's fantastic.
-Yeah. They know what
they're doing, right?
-Well, you know you see them.
I travel a lot, nowadays,
and you see them
in all these advertisements.
You know, when they're
prepping the airplane,
they're doing one thing.
-[ Laughing ] Yeah.
-It's kind of crazy.
Want to get up and --
-[ Laughs ]
-No.
-I would love you not to.
-But they're fun.
A lot of people I know
would love me not to.
No, but they're really good.
They are good.
-And they're taking this
seriously as well
and I think a lot
of young people, right now,
are sort of getting wise
to the fact that
this is going to be
their planet for a lot longer
than it's going to be your
and my planet.
Is there any reason for them
to be optimistic right now?
-Yes. I mean, there is a reason
to be optimistic.
There's also a reason
to be hopeful.
Very hopeful.
You know, just yesterday,
President Biden upped the ante
of what the United States
is going to do
to support the transition
and to help convert
to electric cars
and all the things
we need to do.
And he's committed
about $11 billion
that the United States
is going to deploy,
in order to help the transition.
But, equally importantly,
he's got major legislation
in the Congress.
Try to deploy 500,000
electric vehicle
charging stations
to accelerate this transition.
A tax credit for production,
for investment.
We have to invest.
I mean, in order to get there,
Seth, we have to invest
trillions of dollars
over the next 30 years.
No government
has the kind of money
that's going to make
this transition happen,
so what really encourages me
is the private sector.
They are stepping up
and you have CEOs all
around the world,
you have major
financial institutions,
that are prepared to invest
literally trillions of dollars
in the next 10 years,
which, the scientists tell us,
is the critical period.
-It does seem like
there are some moderates,
even on the Democratic side,
who are maybe trying
to slow this down a little bit.
Has it been frustrating for you
that it doesn't seem to be
that the entire party
is taking this
as seriously as they should?
-No, I think they're
taking it seriously.
What frustrates me
are the people who think
that ivermectin
is going to solve the problem.
-No, yeah, they're problematic.
-You know, I mean,
there's so much disinformation.
There's a whole party that's
waiting for the MyPillow guy
to give them a clue as to what
they ought to do, right?
-[ Laughing ] Yeah.
-That's a problem.
I mean, seriously.
We've lost years, here.
We lost three years
with President Trump.
He pulled
out of the Paris Agreement.
Thank God that governors,
Republicans and Democrats,
alike,
continue to deploy their
renewable portfolio laws
in the states.
So America isn't as far behind
as some people think,
but the world is far behind.
All of us together really have,
you know, a shortened amount
of time to get this job done.
And the kids are absolutely
correct to be furious,
to be frustrated,
to scold us and say,
"Adults, hey, be adults.
Get the job done,"
and that's what
we're trying to do.
-Obviously,
Paris was reported on in 2015,
when you negotiated
that climate agreement.
Now, we're coming up
and you're preparing
for Glasgow in the fall.
-Right.
-And I believe it's being sold
as our last, best chance.
Is that the correct wording?
-It is the correct wording.
I think I've probably
used those words.
Here's where we are.
The scientists have made it
clear to us that --
they made it clear,
three years ago,
that we had 12 years
within which to make
the most critical decisions,
in order to avoid
the worst consequences
of the climate crisis.
So, we lost three years
with President Trump.
Now, we're trying
to make up for it
and we're trying to accelerate.
We have nine years,
within which,
if we don't do enough
to reduce the emissions
that are already out there,
we can't achieve net zero
by 2050.
If we don't do enough
2020, 2030,
we can't keep the Earth's
temperature increase
to the 1.5° that the scientists
say we should try to do.
We're at 1.2° now,
so we've got this tiny cushion
of 0.3° of warming
before things really begin to
snowball out of all proportion.
And that's the fear people have.
We have to take advantage
of these 10 years.
Right now, I'm proud to say,
President Biden's
summit produced
55% of the global
enterprise effort, global GDP.
Is committed on plans
that will hold the 1.5°.
But that means we still have 45%
on the outside of that
and we've got
to pull them together.
Twenty countries, Seth,
are the equivalent of 80%
of all the emissions.
So we're one of them.
We're number 2.
China's number 1.
Russia, India, Mexico.
I mean,
a whole group of countries
have got to step up
in the next days, us included,
and we all have to do better
and do more.
-And when you talk,
I would imagine,
when you discuss the countries
you just listed,
you know, the bigger...
-...the bigger emitters.
The bigger economies.
-And I would imagine the
approach you have with them all
has to be very different.
And, you know, based on being
the secretary of state,
the diplomacy involved
must be very delicate.
-Well, every country
brings its own set
of challenges to the table
and every country believes
that it needs
a certain something to be able
to help them get there.
That's what we're busy
doing right now.
We have a great team of people,
experts, many of whom have
negotiated the Paris Agreement
and have been to the other
meetings over the years.
So, I think we have a good sense
of where we have to go
and how we get there.
We've got to help some countries
to make the leap
that it's better
on the other side, here.
This is not a choice
between protecting
the environment
or having a strong economy.
This, they both
can come together.
And what we know is
that the job creation here
will be just stunning.
I mean, sometimes, you know,
I think about the
United States of America
invented the Internet.
We went to the Moon.
We have a rover on Mars.
We can remotely send it
around Mars.
We do incredible things,
but we can't send an electron
from California to New York
in the year 2021.
That's crazy, and it's insulting
because we could have
an energy system
that's more efficient, that's
more effective, that's cheaper.
And we can use AI,
artificial intelligence.
We can use quantum computing.
We could be ahead of this curve.
And we want --
President Biden wants --
the United States
to lead the effort
to develop the new technologies
to create the capacity
to make this transition
effectively and on time.
And it's all about kids.
You have kids.
I have kids, grandkids.
-Yeah.
-This really is
their world we're talking about
and we need to get
our act together.
-I'm glad you mentioned kids
because I have one last question
I want to leave you with.
The last time I saw you,
we were out and I had my son
and we were both
wearing straw hats
and my son
took off his straw hat
and I put his straw hat
on top of my straw hat
and I'd forgotten
that I had done that.
And then I saw you and I went
over and said hello.
Did you know that I was
wearing two straw hats?
[ Laughter ]
-Not only did I know
that you were wearing
two straw hats,
but when I saw that,
when I saw you,
I said to myself that
George Bush got Will Ferrell
and I got a guy
who wears two hats.
What the hell is going on here?
-How dare you!
[ Laughter ]
How dare you, sir!
John Kerry, everybody.